[Music]
guys at this point what can you really
say about a player like zai woo he is
the king of clutches crowd continues I
will have to shine through in a woman
too he's got the he's a man of many
words what is it like being in front of
this amazing crowd he also happens to be
the recipient of the most MVP awards in
2019 and the score eSports phenom award
2019 in other words he's pretty good
enough that picking and ranking 10 of
his best plays was legitimately
difficult but we did it anyway you're
welcome starting this off is a sick
little play that only a mechanical God
could pull off I'm talking about the
times I we made Mirage his playground
and aced the members of a Gio in a
matter of seconds there were some
legendary names in the French CS seen on
the server that day but honestly who
needs teammates when you can do this
winning out the underpass control capo
with the head for looking off as I lose
either trades it and turns on for the
Tek and maybe my doubts may be
completely awarded as I will drop down
spots Sparrow and deals with him on the
PHR skill
another age defined in this series this
will be the second one purrs I will base
time potentially against the man he's
gonna find it
two aces and two maps for the young star
of vitality and I think I'm actually
been convinced right there coming in at
number nine is a one before clutch
against none other than the greatest
team in cs:go history this time at
dreamhack Masters Malmo 2019 with the
bomb ticking away on vertigo zaboo was
left in a very familiar position
luckily the French prodigy was up to the
task taking down four members of a
stralla with enough time to defuse the
bomb and the USP one tap for the final
kill Oh c'est magnifique
who's gonna have a fighting retreat but
he's been worried about the flight he
knows that asteroids has been working
this maps so well there's one shot Vegas
not gonna be able to punish him good
follow up from Z whoo but they're still
searching and he's got another that's
three kills on the right he can go for
this he can go for this no Michael I
don't think he's gonna win it
Oh Ellis over tendons Iroh has pulled
something out of nowhere it's so
ridiculous especially the way that he
finishes it yeah one tap just the wee
little one time that one time at the
grand finals of ESL one cologne 2019
zero and vitality came face to face with
the then darlings of counter-strike an
ace powerhouse team liquid after tl
brutalized vitality in map one it was I
whoo-hoo once again a stepped-up put his
team on his back
and closed out map two in overtime with
this 1v3 clutch and I were to get the
ball back again we said double overtime
isn't out a possibility is an
unbelievable
but it might be was I who finally and
exhaust like that is he stepped back
into the door
anyone plants there's no rush slow it
down as now
and hey while vitality didn't end up
winning the tournament zai was
phenomenal performance alone earned him
his third hltv MVP award of the year
number seven is an ace clutch from the
young French god this time against forza
in the mountain dew league from may 2019
40 seconds into the round zai who finds
himself alone with the bomb in hand and
miles away from a site now if there's
any player in the world right now
who's gonna pull this off you better
believe it's gonna be zai world 32 now
to his names I ruin the one versus five
and AWP in his hands and see what he's
able to do is it sports up ahead yeah
thanks to power eliminated that's the
first of what could be many more there's
a man who wears a cape on a server it
gotta be signed with a body shot coming
down to Alameda that's the second and
he's starting to build up the pressure
for force pop is the magic stick you
wanna see the fern Frank found and he's
hungry for more he seems to have
somewhat of a realization what's about
to happen
as Jerry comes in and sneaks very slowly
to get closer and closer to the a sight
both seems to be frozen in staying there
and waiting patiently as now it is only
a move from xyu to turn things around to
smoke has land its Howard CT face crack
is gonna approach back over toilets zai
who has the read he has the
understanding and he has the interest
another and is this man cannot stop
getting them down one by one by one it's
a final frak he needs together and it's
Jerry take it out as well site will
Europe East your maniac and your the
personal Grim Reaper of vitality who's
humiliating them all the truly sickening
thing about this play is just how easy
he makes it all look
taking the number six spot on our list
is another of the many moments at ESL
one cologne 2019 in which is I will earn
the moniker of prodigy with the clock
ticking away in a 1 V 3 clutch against
one of Anna's best rosters sang-woo
lined up a ridiculous collateral to stop
Energy's initial attempt at a plant
we're treating back to spawn to let time
run out like any smart player would say
whew thought he done enough but even a
heroic last-second bob plan by tarik
wasn't enough to deny the God of French
CS good double kill for him and now it's
all on side wall here 14 seconds left oh
oh no the bomb punt it might be right in
front and now we just need to wait they
can't find the bomb anymore in the last
possible second and side was back for
more looking for him already with the
triple just needs one more clicker less
common tarik is hiding behind Tetris
side windows who's got two back Jill's
winning it for mentality you've never
seen anything like it
what a ridiculous performance coming in
at the halfway point is the time the
desire really started putting the csgo
world on notice with some fans calling
him deep French is simple what did he do
to earn that name for himself
oh just single-handedly ace hellraisers
with the scout against head armor Jesus
why are we waiting come with the scout
at the edge there's the kill on two
Hobbit advantage picked up in fight al
they would love to get a little bit more
here and sideways got himself a triple
kill with a scout quad from Skyward and
it's in two or three v1 inside water Z
is incredible stuff from zero that's
another is that we've seen today from
zai would incredible stuff on the scout
hellraisers walked right into that one
and the yarn French Super Start knocks
them all over
at number four on our list is yet
another disgusting ace clutch from our
favorite Frenchman this time on one of
CS goes biggest stages the starladder
major after failing to execute the
classic rush b matchmaking strat on
dust2 the french prodigy turns what was
an inevitable round loss for vitality
into some good old Zulu magic this would
be such a historic comeback brush repeat
its a classic piece out in the open
chest out fighting every single one and
somehow he comes out way on top side
whenever trying to fight his way back
and he's gonna have to get the ACE to
try and shut this round to health and
bring his team maybe finally back into
the game a little bit he's got the right
idea but ad rent again is such a smart
player
he's been playing forever and he's
sneaking up behind side who still can't
get the kill and now it's on G ready and
waiting side wall is just tapping away
at the door he won the fight is he gonna
be able to get it still alive and only
in 56 health that's not a lot against
that USB he fakes the bomb a single
timer he's got
[Applause]
that is such a sweet way at number three
we have xilu absolutely victimizing
energy for the second time on this list
this time during the semi-finals of ECS
season seven in London
with the North Americans swarming the a
bomb site on overpass young met you
single-handedly shuts down energies push
from outside of bathrooms in a play that
makes one of counterstrikes top teams
look like a silver matchmaking squad to
use that opportunity to make their way
all the way towards the a-site circus Oh
away hit it off cut it hit this shot he
was ready for it his eye route will take
him down it's back to the forum for
Stephanie one long but sir 30 seconds
remaining as I was in one of the most
overlooked positions in cs:go
[Applause]
absolutely unbelievable and he just puts
the whole team taking the runner-up spot
on our list is a series ending play that
not only left viewers at home in awe but
that casters themselves with vitality on
match point against ends at CS summit
for zai we took matters into his own
hands with the play up banana so
aggressive so balls to the wall
he would make simple blush massively on
their tee shot as well they're
anticipating banana first he's had
enough he's gonna keep going through it
he doesn't really care
couldn't make it up that's it boys
football on Henry put a fork in it Jason
it's done coming in at number one on our
list is a play from ESL one cologne 2019
that typifies what it means to be a
phenom what it means to be a prodigy and
what it means to be zero balanced on a
Razors Edge this sublime clutch is a mix
of aggression cerebral play and pure raw
skill plays like this is why we love
counter-strike apex will sit back
towards the point can all a check for
the open or a single kill coming in all
that steps up worry toaster brawl and as
I will eventually drop him on the floor
but it has to be the one before
quadrants I would need to come same
barely enough health to survive here on
brawler both sigh he wants to kill
there's the head shot pulled the fact
that your bird's eye was got the triple
cribs is the last man standing and
there's time for the tea fuse so ever
wants to smoke the bomb if you're crazy
have to be stirred and cyber wins it
that is unbelievable from the young
Frenchman a team vitality will get a 16
this man always steps up when vitality
need him the most towards those key
rounds what is this ah well that's it
for the top tens I will plays at least
so far but I think you guys agree the
way this kid is going we could be here a
year from now with an entirely new list
okay Collins predictions for 2020 csgo
faze clan win every event both majors
become the greatest dynasty in the
history of csgo
even greater than a stralla somehow in
one year phase up we back baby
yeah
[Music]